It's hard to believe that Adam Sandler was
once one of the most successful comedy actors
in Hollywood.
But since his glory days, Sandler has tumbled
pretty hard.
In flop after flop, his career appears beyond
repair.
What's really behind Sandler's stagnant trajectory?
Costly and Crappy
The infamous Sony hacks from 2014 revealed
that Sandler was regarded by many studio executives
as a waste of money.
One Sony employee wrote:
"We continue to be saddled with mundane, formulaic
Adam Sandler films."
Another exec said that Sandler's excessive
private jet usage on the studio's dime was
"stressing [him] out."
He went on to detail trips of Sandler's costing
in excess of $68,000 a flight.
Perhaps, suggested the executive, Netflix—with
whom Sandler had recently partnered—could
share the costs of the failing star's offices
on the lot, which ran the studio $2 million
a year.
Then again, maybe not...
Netflix's Regrets
Sandler's first release of his four-picture
deal with Netflix, The Ridiculous 6, garnered
publicity in all the wrong ways.
During filming, a dozen Native American actors
walked off-set after hearing what they felt
were racist jokes.
But when it was finally released, the movie
actually set a record as the most-watched
film on Netflix within its first 30 days.
Then again, the film was harshly criticized
for what many saw as its racist concept and
undertones.
The Ridiculous 6 managed to score a ridiculous
0% on Rotten Tomatoes.
Print is Dead...To Him
Sandler himself doesn't seem interested in
challenging his unfavorable media portrayal.
After press junkets for Billy Madison, he
apparently read some unfavorable descriptions
of himself and decided to stop talking to
print journalists altogether—an arrangement
no one really seems to mind.
These days, Sandler's Twitter feed, perhaps
his best means of reaching fans, is hardly
engaging.
No Ladies' Man
Sandler has also earned a bad marks for his
portrayals and relationships with women in
Hollywood.
In June of 2016, actress Rose McGowan tweeted
out a casting notice she'd received for one
of Sandler's movies that encouraged women
auditioning to wear "form-fitting tanks that
show off cleavage—push-up bras encouraged."
Soon after calling out Sandler on Twitter,
McGowan said she was fired by her agent, and
a social media outcry erupted.
Meanwhile, at a premiere for Hotel Transylvania
2, he and co-star Kevin James, both in what
appeared to be gym clothes, were photographed
next to a very dressed-up Selena Gomez.
The images sparked a debate online about double
standards for men and women in Hollywood.
And seriously, c'mon guys—you don't own
shirts with buttons?
Sandler may have played a girl in Jack and
Jill, but he doesn't seem to relate well with
them.
“Ow!
Oh my god!”
Stale Co-Stars
Comedy posses are no new phenomena, especially
among SNL alumni.
But Sandler's insistence on working time and
again with actors like David Spade, Kevin
James, and Rob Schneider may be preventing
him from reaching younger fans.
He did hire Natasha Leggero for his Netflix
release The Do-Over, but relegated her to
a supporting "crazy wife" role, leaving the
more substantial acting to David Spade.
In the case of The Do-Over, this resulted
in yet another slew of disastrous reviews.
But hey, at least it earned higher praise
than his previous outing!
Where The Ridiculous 6 had a mind-boggling
0% on Rotten Tomatoes, The Do-Over blows it
out of the water with...a five percent.
“I award you no points, and may god have
mercy on your soul.”
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know why
you think Adam Sandler's career isn't what
it used to be…